uh welcome everybody to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have
another og cast today we got that
special special special guest Patrick T
Riley saying we have this [ __ ] this
guy why are you this guy you build them
up and then you built you break me down
but it's necessary you just ruin the
whole mood of the PAC's [ __ ] nice all
good what you been up to man chillin man
just doing stand-up working same old
same old being a papa the first story
were actually saw how your daughter look
that's like that's a cute ass we should
have her on dude she probably has a lot
of wisdom stop [ __ ] with these homes
how old is she she's 2 now dude
d yeah so she talks and [ __ ] and she's
uh she's adorable dude and like she
talks a gang and like she has like her
own little personality it's starting to
come out you know to me and she's like
she gives me attitude and sass sometimes
and I'm saying like hell walk out on
your life you know that could leave you
and then she starts acting right right
away right yeah well I don't know she
doesn't get it she doesn't like me I
think she she stares at me when I try to
say hi to her and she just gives me the
dead stare like what you're giving me
right now she's like she likes you she
just warm so she'd say it takes time
you're weird though you know you tried
too hard you're like and she's like I
feel like when you get married you gonna
have a kid real soon
no I don't know cast honestly I was me
and if we're talking about the other
night like we went to go hang out with a
Jason and their kids and then Heinrich
about his daughter over and they're
great and they're they're the sweetest
kids ever but just having kids to worry
about all the time just stresses me out
they're like running around the house
and the whole time I'm thinking like
[ __ ] were if they fall and hit their
head or some [ __ ] kids are [ __ ] crazy
and it's a handful like Anna and I told
TIFF as soon as I got back and I love
their kids too
oh yeah Shia Heinrich by the way shots
of their kids I love them
but it's just like having all that
responsibility it's nice to be able to
like leave that and then just hydrate
likes to give his daughter
baskin-robbins room with a head all
crazy being a little sweetie
she was being such a little sweetheart
but it's also like it's just kids
it's just you have string anywhere no
matter how great the kids are they're
always gonna be like oh my god this is
this is a lot of work it's not just like
the work of like like you said watch out
for this table but like you're always
focusing on them because like they could
eat like they'll just start eat glass
but it's so like you're always like kind
of like worried about like what the [ __ ]
is going on and it's crazy because like
I used to see stand up about like dads
talking about like that how tiring it is
I'm gonna get a break and it's so true
dudes like when I go like I take like 20
minutes shits now like if my mom's home
and like with my daughter like I sit in
there like I'm like [ __ ] I need a reset
in here for like but it's like you just
need you because like you're so focused
on them all the time like and they're
just like a like running around like so
you need like a little like a little
like just a brief I just need a breather
yeah we went to learning curve for sure
though we went to Hawaii and then
originally it was just supposed to be a
trip with me and Mariel and then y'all
got throwed out there's like you I'm
gonna go to why you guys when it goes
like yeah we'll bring the kids and then
this is gonna be interesting
and you know it was like a quick trip so
I was like why not just have everybody
come and then Merida was only gonna be
there for a couple days now she has to
fly back anyways so I was like you guys
come around it'll be fun and just
watching them have having to deal with
two kids
it was the most exhausting [ __ ] they're
ever seen in my [ __ ] life man don't
touch that don't do this don't do this
pick him up here grabbing there change
their diapers especially when they're in
San and then you have to dust all the
sand off every beach we had to go if
they had to take the kid wash him off
redress him and do it every [ __ ] time
wanted to blow my brains out my kids
yeah it takes forever and it's not like
they're like oh yeah dust it off yeah
they're like come on this is for your
[ __ ] benefit let me dust you off yeah
like Tycho was screaming his [ __ ]
brains out because he has a little bit
fear of water because onion bar bar
chart a drought well he had a life vest
feel super safe but a big wave came and
didn't see it and then Bart I guess he
got hit by the water he looked up
Tycho's god
that's so scary got a little traumatized
with the water but then they figured out
that it's because a second control thing
right so when the kid feels like he's
not in control he starts to freak out
rather they put one of those little
floaty rings around him and he's like a
little bit above the water [ __ ] loved
it mmm having the time of his [ __ ]
life mmm you guys are cured his uh his
like phobia of water and kids are hard
to figure out too because you don't know
what the [ __ ] they want man yeah cuz he
was scared of the water and then they
took him out of the water then he
started crying cuz he wasn't in the
water yeah so what do you wanna do just
put hands on swing man you wanna take
this outside
[ __ ] you tell me what you want like it
you obviously it's wrong to beat the
[ __ ] out of your kids but like you can
totally understand you get it like man I
should just [ __ ] you up right now yeah
like this is the same way not a [ __ ]
dog I would crack you in your teeth
girls when we were kids yes I would do
some [ __ ] so true that my mom would just
beat the [ __ ] out of us for all the time
and then now as I get older I realize
I'm like oh yeah that's totally
understandable she would just beat the
[ __ ] out of us just for being like you
know this verge is being used as baby
just woke up she came in swinging
she's like [ __ ] throwing kicks it
miss those days man
I miss those days when he's get my ass
beat yeah you know when I look back on I
think I really deserved half the beans I
got they're all for sure I'm almost a
hundred percent sure I deserved most of
it I just didn't like the way they
handle their anger yeah on my face my
mom's rules were so done though cuz she
would she would look at my dad ish as if
she was like the moral high ground in
the in their relationship because my dad
would [ __ ] me up and then he wouldn't
miss his swing a little bit and the sock
me in the face my mom's like told you
are you a mobster I'm like oh yeah but
the [ __ ] okay he like slaps me in the
face she goes don't you dare think I
care about the twenty lashings on my
back to [ __ ] Tyson hooks to the liver
stretch on the ropes at bottom yeah my
dad once beat me so bad so he you know
like those uh old wiffle ball sets those
mean that hard plastic gin and then you
hit it with a wiffle ball [ __ ] my dad
beat me with this blue wiffle ball bat
so [ __ ] bad I didn't go to school for
weeks I couldn't send the charity dance
oh [ __ ] I could I forgot what the [ __ ] I
did though yeah you for sure blocked you
buried that memory yeah I don't remember
what I did but I remember he beat me so
bad I had a sit I had a late sleep on my
stomach cuz I couldn't lay down on my
ass because it hurt so older damn I had
to be like in the fourth grade or
something and I think my dad I don't
know man
like I'm not trying to justify this but
I was a pretty bad kid so I'm pretty
sure I was just uh just I was just crazy
and I remember afterwards this full he
put tiger balm on my ass and it burned
so bad I started crying and he was in
tears laughing and he just couldn't stop
laughing I remember he brought my mom
over to laugh at me too
they were both I bet even [ __ ] I was
laying in bed with my [ __ ] pants
around my ankles right as he put the
tiger balm I'm crying cuz it burned so
much he grabbed I remember I looked up
he grabbed my mom into the room so she
could laugh at me and they're literally
at my door laughing at me so funny it
was my birthday I don't know I don't
think I'd uh I don't think I'd hit my
kids I'm gonna try not to no I don't
think I wouldn't hit my for sure you
just like I'm just verbally abuse them
she's adorable baby I'm throwing crosses
that are right in the middle dude they
do you would you like tap her hand or
something like that to or no no I like
what I'll do is cuz like sometimes
she'll get mad and like try to hit me
yeah what a kids [ __ ] do that yeah
cuz they're little animals or they don't
know they don't know you think you're
tough
I came out of a [ __ ] to hear it was
rough it there for me [ __ ] no oxygen
my belly button swing at me sometimes so
that what I'll do is I'll hold her hand
and I'll be like nah like you can't do
that yeah but like I don't want to hit
her or anything like that I try to
explain [ __ ] sometimes I'll raise my
voice a little bit but like it's just
like you're so much
you're like a like a you have to
discipline them but like you're so much
like there are a [ __ ] baby yeah I
can't even imagine like how like just
taking off on her like some parents are
just like [ __ ] dudes up my my my
friend damn she she has a she's a crazy
little kid right she's a single mom
mm-hmm
kids like hyper I'm for sure he has like
whatever ADHD or some [ __ ] like that but
like she spanks him and I I can
understand why because he doesn't he
can't register anything but he's such a
boy he's like a boys boy you know what I
mean
like plays with rocks throw [ __ ] all the
time and she could sit there like I've
seen her sit there and try to talk to
him like very sternly and then do
everything doesn't work but she'll go
right to the back side his head he goes
okay and he just sits it's like down
yeah yeah for her it's just like like I
don't got time for this [ __ ] but it's
most effective though you know little
Cesar Millan that's fine it's like some
kids are harder so like in that
situation I think that's fine I think
she's got a little it out yeah for sure
i'ma have to uppercut my kid though yeah
he just gave me a demon spawn or if you
have two kids one of them's gonna be
like the sweetheart and the other one's
gonna be like testing you that's the
best he's gonna test my brothers like
the the really caught he went to UCSD
your brother's so calm oh yeah when we
after we went to go get drinks in
Koreatown or j-town remember oh yeah
yeah after we were driving back TIFF was
like John and David are so different
oh yeah first of all he's like five
seven mm-hmm yeah dude really slender
tiny guy sweet soul I'm the I'm at the
spawn of decency
he's completely opposite me like yeah
even when we grew up he has a huge dick
no
as relative to his body so I have a
regular dick on a big body so it looks
small in their mouth they're like mmm
not that bad it's just like Indonesian
food it looks like trash but it tastes
great
all right so shout out the top
restaurant oh yeah shout out I love that
lady dude her volume is really high what
she speaks yeah she was yelling orders
oh yeah know what's going on even if I
didn't say it was good she probably
[ __ ] me uh yeah I've been going to
that restaurant dude probably well we've
been going there probably for a couple
years like randomly in and out but now
since we live closer and now my job is a
lot closer this speaking of TIFF dude
this guy is a creep yeah we found out
today how he asked for sex and I'll tell
you this man unacceptable me too me too
creepy sure it's very loving it starts
with kissing and hugging and then I go
so you won't do this or what and then
she looks at me and says I have
pneumonia she was she was out for two
weeks so apparently so here here this is
where it started okay I talked to
Patrick and I'm like Pat man like I just
want to help like my girl feel better
like she has pneumonia and he goes have
sex with her abuse a boost immune system
so I was like okay so I take that and I
bring it back to TIFF and I say hey you
know I heard my buddy told me that if we
have sex you're gonna feel a lot better
and then she goes who is it and I said
Patrick and then she goes no we're not
gonna have sex and that's alright to
have sex with your fiance when she had a
viral infection listen here's here's the
thing if she says yes we're playing ball
baby
whether she does it how I'm how
infectious is pneumonia I don't know
that's not an infectious is it
infectious I don't know it's lifted up
oh you don't have pneumonia right now so
I do that not yet [ __ ] I might I might
hit me like [ __ ] two weeks later you
never know yeah but I don't have it yet
so I'm good well if you want it if you
want to have sex with tip how do you how
do you
go about it how do you do it because you
seem like the more aggressive one and
she's like work and Nick's just butt-ass
in the living room like hi babe
and like that's it it's funny cuz every
time she posts a story of me or
something on our Instagram I'm always
like not wearing it I just picture you
butt-naked on the couch and then you
take to [ __ ] cards and you put it
over your dick that's the size of your
dick if you open up some tiny penis like
it's just like a small little nut it
opens up like it like a sped up video of
the flappers that's almost pretty
accurate but they pointed that mic isn't
it I think she goes why are you trying
to sex with me I'm like I just tell her
I'm like I'm just trying to shoot my
shot that's the she up is she that she
does she ever approach you to have sex
that's what I was just gonna yeah yeah
sometimes question yeah sometimes you
like she's very businesslike about ages
she goes like 3 p.m. she does it only
that's it that's my style you'll be
doing no she just
um she just like I don't like not jumps
on me but like she just starts she
starts pressing the facts so I'm just
kind of like start hugging me and
kissing me and then oh so she gives you
clear signs or sitting down and then
should start pushing my head down this
box home it is mother [ __ ] give us
ethers muffuletta
first of all tip is like the sweetest
girl ever she's been talking like that
at all
Masha's she does she does she speaks she
cussing Spanish cuz I don't know she
does yeah she calls me like a dog and
you don't ever just try to like sots her
up before you have sex you just go right
at it you I start krumping for her nice
yeah because I'm bringing about sex I'm
very back he's got a clown makeup on
he's trying to clown yeah yeah I guess
we have to have sex yeah just got to
kiss him on the neck give them a couple
pets on the puss
if it's dry you know it's not tired yeah
you're like oh there's no heat coming
out of it oh good this podcast is
brought to you by purple baby listen
have you had
nice sleep probably because you don't
have a purple mattress now I just gotta
tell you I've had the best night sleeps
at my life since my purple mattress it's
all about finding a mattress that
understands you it's all about finding a
mattress that understands that you need
something that's firm but soft at the
same time we're looking for balance and
that's what a purple mattress does now
if you don't know this already you sleep
a big big major majority of your life
and if you're not getting good sleep
it's probably because you're not
sleeping on something really comfortable
that really gets you to get in that deep
sleep spot and my purple mattress has
been helping me get the best sleep of my
life because prior to this mattress I
was sleeping on a springy piece of
doodoo babe
so if you guys don't know the technology
behind April mattress is developed by
rocket scientists there's a lot of great
things about this and if you don't
already know my friends it's the best so
check this out you're going to love
purple and right now my listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just takes a brain to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
brain to eight four eight eight eight
that's br8 in2 eight four - eight eight
eight it's like when you check the soil
on a plan to see if you see if it's
ready to be watered again just give a
little tap - how do you do it how would
you how do you - pro I just told you
kiss them on the neck go to the puss go
was try how do you do it Patrick Patrick
has many lovers ah I don't that's not
true at all have many lovers just go you
know I just walk in and we sit down have
some coffee or something like that yeah
yeah so usually you have sex like like
after a coffee shop after you sometimes
it just it depends you know you just
start you don't you just start kissing
and [ __ ] this guy is the biggest mack
daddy it's not true I'm not he loves me
your ways maybe got a guy that is a true
mack daddy would say what he just said
and you're a true mack daddy I don't
know but I'm not a date today
we were at getting coffee and then this
girl was like oh my god like they were
like chatting it up there was such a
dirty like I know how to and that's how
it started but I'm not sitting macdaddy
do you use the mack daddy what are you a
[ __ ] 70 year old young blood you're
walking around like this job to with you
man yeah I'm you sound like a Filipino
uncle did you know who's the mack daddy
over here over here when he goes up to
the that's ready to go ready to go yeah
what would you go would you say instead
of mack daddy what would you say pimp a
G the G nah yeah look like a slick mack
daddy just it's just driving the point
home a little bit oh yes Massa daddy is
a machina ho hey yeah but but Patrick
gets a lot of girls it's not I mean now
it's really I mean no because I we have
other friends were like literally liked
it like one of our buddies
his name's Diego this dude like I met
him in middle school we were 12 he's
like having threesomes every weekend
like it was just like neck like what
dude I'm in algebra I haven't even
kissed a girl you're [ __ ] having
threesomes it's like yeah dawg it's
pretty sick
like there's dudes like that that are
like for reals like which diello is
around girls he like is totally blowing
him off like he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
just kind of like just his handsome
handsome man he's a good looking but
it's also like just his like he just
knows what he said I don't know you
don't get this [ __ ] dude cuz I've known
a couple of guys who have told me about
their threesome situations and it's like
how did you just fall into this cuz I
don't know how I don't know who I don't
know how to lob it up yeah yeah yeah
almost had to to and I [ __ ] them both
them what I've learned from my mistakes
I'm ready for number three I've learned
I've taken some notes the first one uh
first of all you got to let it kind of
just happen I got two weeks
it's gonna happen like yeah come on it's
like what do you do for a threesome like
how do you guys start a threesome yes
like that these girls it's already
starting to hook up and I was oh my god
and I was like whoa so you just sat
there and just watched her whoa se
that's what I felt we're doing but see
actually that's kind of the MOOC so I I
felt like a weirdo sitting there I felt
like I wanted I needed to participate I
could feel anyone could see I jumped in
too soon and they were kind of like like
I wasn't I'm yeah I like let them heat
up a little bit let it heat the water
like the water boil pull a kick out of
the other too fast yeah yeah exactly so
I jumped into a ball great analogy I
just was like - I was in my head like
yes like it's just like my life's [ __ ]
perfect I just looking was a super ants
but I [ __ ] up and I was like damn well
how do you how do you well what are you
supposed to do you see two vaginas in
front of you and you're just like yeah I
just gotta play it off a real cooler
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] I would explode
yeah you put it but you do have to like
you have to jump in at the right it's
like double dutch you jump in too soon
you [ __ ] up the whole rhythm is so
technique comes in go up to the [ __ ]
bop bop yep that's right
I can't believe you almost had two
threesomes which is also like what yeah
yeah I mean a threesome who me yeah
he'll [ __ ] know yeah so I want to get
a twosome going on yeah that's why we're
on this side of like it's like the most
difficult you know what it is - it's
because I'm too much of a pastor cuz I
like I'll get a girl to open up talk
we're having a good time and then I'm
like you have so many issues let's talk
about you me and crying yeah crying and
I'm like there's like you're a good
friend I'm like my [ __ ] this up didn't I
yeah I should have just said put it in
your mouth and instead what I said is
have you met the Lord yeah and now they
go to church and they're married yeah
what's wrong with me did your pass on
all these the threesome opportunities oh
no I don't think anybody would ever have
a threesome with me I wouldn't even know
what to do with there are some girls who
are so [ __ ] fine like I know dudes
that'll look at look at chicks right I'm
gonna go - I can't you don't know what
I'd do if I
getting that ass bless your pants that's
what she do you know what I like there's
some women I [ __ ] you not let's just say
like they're so [ __ ] fine they came
up to me and they're like let's [ __ ] I
would say no because I'd be too nervous
yeah I wouldn't know what to do with all
that ass I wouldn't know what to do
[ __ ] and I think like oh the type of
guys that she [ __ ] it's way better
than me so I don't want to set her up as
a disappointment now she'll never [ __ ]
another asian guy so I don't want to do
a disservice to people so I'll just pass
it on to the next person yeah I'll pass
it on to the big old black dude with a
fat cop but that's the other thing too
is like if a girl was very forward I
like I wouldn't know what that would be
like uh I'd feel very scenario right now
have an aggressive woman okay this has
happened before - yes only once
hey let's your name my name my name is
Nick hmm my [ __ ] strike you're the
woman you are you and go hyah
welcome to Phil's coffee what can I get
for you today
I get a filtered soul iced so you come
here often or what that's you being
really cool you know why because this is
what happened today - Patrick I just
talk to you it's like how's your day
going bah bah she's just being flirty
it wasn't crazy she wasn't like hey lis
meet me in the back [ __ ] if she would
have said that honestly I would have
been like okay yeah see I'm the guy
that's like what are you setting me up
for I do get my times are you is your
boyfriend gonna come out and put a gun
to my head and Rob me like that's what I
think and that's that's happened to me
before
has it knob Jackie not but like that'd
be pretty good that'd be a cool story
I really wonder because you've been with
TIFF for so [ __ ] long do you even
know what you would do if you now go
back into the dating game or the dating
world in general
I predict would be good though I know I
know you're probably super rusty you
probably whatever but like cuz Nick's
charming and funny [ __ ] up dude I'm
telling you would kill it Charley do man
he just lacks confidence yeah man
charming ass [ __ ] gay BJ's
okay not 50k dude 750 can't make it 700
makes it a big difference let's do it
for free at that point yeah interesting
I would suck dick you know I would just
to get back out there you suck a dick
would you what would happen if you were
single though don't you don't you think
about that [ __ ] like if let's say
tomorrow TIFF just happens to die right
well god forbid god forbid I loved her
but she got it pneumonia because you
thought you dick with the vaccinations
and old timey [ __ ] disease yeah she
she didn't have sex with you her immune
system didn't get inside here this here
this baby I love you listen to this pot
yeah hell yeah so you have penicillin in
your dick yeah if she didn't take it she
dies right the funeral happens whatever
now you're in your apartment by yourself
all alone yeah yeah what is your next
move probably get evicted okay she's the
Brethren no I don't know I don't know I
really I probably would just not do
anything for a really long time tinder
oh they're probably not I you know me
I'd probably if I were on tinder and
somebody would like hit me up and be
like hey what's up I would just be like
hey and then that would be it that's how
that's how I've seen people live looking
at people's tenders and inboxes and it
seems like that a lot and I'm for sure
that guy that's not gonna be like oh so
like I don't have anything [ __ ] cute
or witty to say I'm not that dude I
don't have pickup lines like that but is
it pickup lines are [ __ ] lame I know
but like the conversation going
ya know like you're funny you'd be all
right I think it would take you a minute
but how come you can't just be yourself
and just be funny you know I can be in
the right context but then everyone's
gonna be like oh my god but nikki is
such a relationship kind of guy you know
you are yes you you would never hit it
and quite it I like what I like you know
I mean and I just like I like building a
bond with certain people and casual
relation it's like converting people to
Christianity because all I do that's my
move man
what would you do what would you do
David oh it's easy this dude gets post
everywhere it's not it's not easy it's
more like definitely I already had a
conversation with Mariel about this I
was like if one of us happens to die
just but just we have a very casual
conversation I told him for sure I don't
think I would be in a serious
relationship for at least like six or
seven years
point developed like five strong years
with her and I have to do all that [ __ ]
over again are you [ __ ] crazy yeah
that's that's a I think about that a lot
and I think I can't do it I don't have
the strength I think about all the stuff
that means if went through for us to
kind of be where we're at today yeah
it's a lot of [ __ ] work I can't
figure out when they're gonna have their
period and the Hardman but then like hot
like like dealing with somebody else and
then like building a new relationship
with somebody oh and you got to figure
out how personal trauma that they had in
their past relationship with their
father and their mother I don't care
anymore
they're our friends now they want to
talk to me about their life problems I'm
like [ __ ] you I have this lady I have to
deal with she takes all my energy so
whatever I have left is then yours but
until then [ __ ] off yeah I I don't care
I don't care I don't care I really don't
but I don't know if I'd uh get into a
serious relationship after but for sure
just go right back in dating pal what's
the longest relationship you've been in
six days probably like teachers you're
gonna have two years I mean Emily I
lived with her are together for like a
year and a half two years fell apart
living with somebody is [ __ ] hard
dude let's have party except I have
living together it's just like well I
mean a lot of things we were kind of
like incompatible in certain ways but
like when we were just dating it was
cool but like when you live with
somebody it's like damn you like you
just can't get a [ __ ] like they're
always that always but that happened
quick though - and it's like you
wouldn't have to know somebody she also
caught me watching porn in that what's
the problem she used to think porn was
cheating
what so yeah I dude there's a whole
there's a whole [ __ ] thing that's
actually thought Patrick is cheating on
her in the beginning of our relationship
I remember I made a joke about porn like
this is a still in the
getting-to-know-you face we hadn't like
hooked up or anything
yeah and she was like dude she was like
porn is disgusting and I was like I mean
you'd sure she was she was like now like
porn she's like I think porn is cheating
and I was like that's like I was like
that's pretty extreme you're like that's
[ __ ] stupid that's what you said and
she said well if you watch porn we could
just stop talking right now date anybody
dude I'm gonna start dating girls
probably by the way ladies if you meet a
guy
and you guys are having a conversation
let's say you met this dude on tinder
all right tandra uganda honda you're
talking and he says to you point blank
to your face he goes I don't watch porn
that stuff is disgusting he is watching
children porn
he is masturbating to little kids faces
and on top of that he's a rapist because
the [ __ ] yeah he's everybody cuz for
me I could I can confidently say I don't
watch as much porn as I used to does not
mean I don't watch porn right yeah I
mean I don't watch as much as I used to
still watch it every now and then of
course it's not as normal yeah that's
what I but in that moment because it was
the beginning where I was still like
damn I want to hook up with this guy I
would like no I don't really watch like
I've seen it but like I don't I don't
know I've seen friends try to make me
watch it I cover my butt that's a bro
good answer but then we ended up living
together and then she caught me one day
and I was like what were you watching
but what's her reaction to yeah what
were you watching okay I don't remember
what I was watching but I was definitely
on spank bank calm that's one of my
college it's still up develop and run
all those porn sites are for sure have
like a longevity yeah no one's taking
those down dude pink bang so I was on
that and she was supposed to be at work
till 4:00 it was like 1:00 I didn't have
a job at the time of this it was like
extra loser [ __ ] what does she expect
you to that of course you're gonna jack
off the porn you have a job I got a
sweetie fun no it's 1:00 p.m. I'm like
[ __ ] I'm gonna I feel like jerking
off right now that's what I'm gonna do
and I was done like I was like cleaning
up but I was an idiot I left the website
up and I came out I was in my boxers and
she was standing in the living room and
I was just like huh
you're still like half hard so you're
[ __ ] pitching damn my boxers and I
was like hi you should is this right
when you saw the porn on the screen just
looked at it been like I can't believe
you're watching what are you doing yeah
I'm so sick of this and you start
breaking [ __ ] in the house and before
she say anything and you just leave so
what was the ripple effect after she
well okay so so the video was still like
is it just [ __ ] everything up cuz like
if she was like super insecure I'll get
I'll get to that in a second but like so
the video wasn't up it was off but the
ad was on like you know this [ __ ]
weirdo ads like up goblins [ __ ]
unicorns
like it made me look like it just like
to her was like a [ __ ] watching it's
like a huge monster [ __ ] good but
it's also like it's also like a game
like every time I see that [ __ ] some
do that face so anyway so okay just a
[ __ ] up the trust in the relationship
and then but then that's when I was like
I had the conversation with her then
that I should have had at the beginning
which was what is the problem what is
your problem with porn and she was like
I just want to be the only woman you
desire nice try impossible that's
exactly I was like that's not possible
well this isn't a Disney movie we're not
in [ __ ] suck yeah because I love
Muriel and I want to be with only her
for the rest of my life sure but if a
nice ass walks by in that flash moment I
desire that but sure you know it's not a
choice it's not like I don't decide to
go oh I'm gonna think this girl's
[ __ ] fine three two one day I'm like
it just like she walks in and you're
like [ __ ] yeah like I would have to say
some really just like non just like the
most fucked-up [ __ ] to my head just to
like Pavlov myself off of women would
you you can't it's impossible it's not
it's not possible and that's what I was
trying to explain and I kind of [ __ ]
up like I said this I realize now that
this is condescending but at the time I
thought I was just like it weird like
dudes were straightforward like cool and
I was like trying to relate to her so I
was like you know what I felt exactly
the way you do right now about not
wanting your partner to desire anyone
else except I was in seventh grade like
I didn't I wasn't like I was like I
thought that in middle school but III
don't realize how much of an ass but
like I said that and it definitely
didn't help my case at all
and she was like she was like now like
you're addicted immediately relax do you
wanna cheat and I was like I don't
actually jerking off prevents like many
desires of cheating I get it out of the
way we're cool you know what I mean but
there's I was trying to explain like you
said like I just I can't help not be
attracted to people like if if you see
an attractive dude you're gonna think
that guy's attractive it's normal it's
normal and she was like I'm only
attracted to personality and such you
should horseshit [ __ ]
you walk in front of a bus right now
[ __ ]
the dumb I [ __ ] hate it when [ __ ]
people do that well she's logged oh
really I did it guys today we're just
going to talk about porta they should be
[ __ ] she's like today we're gonna check
my boyfriend's browser history and there
is nothing on it he's probably using
incognito mode
yeah ro but she so she considered
watching porn cheating because you
mentally desired somebody else besides
her it's like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's
like telling me right now right that's
why I love I like chicken right but
every now and then
look at some scripts but if I dedicated
myself to chicken sometimes I'll miss it
like it's like somebody who's switched
to being a vegan for more reason doesn't
mean the bank won't Cray mistake every
now sure exactly yeah I mean yeah but
does vegan they're not eating no steak
right but they crave it now and then
yeah and it's not that there's nothing
wrong with it especially like for us
we're animals like we don't control that
yeah yeah what the teacher yeah it was
really insecure so that just kind of
spiraled into a bunch of [ __ ] and I cuz
I she knows where porn addiction is I
think she was she that was like her
auto-response right cuz porn addiction
which I know somebody who has a porn
addiction and he's working on it right
now
and for him it was more along the lines
of like I think for him he had to
realize that it was affecting his
everyday that's what an addiction is it
affects your everyday life like
functioning working you can't have sex
with your partner you don't find them
attractive anymore you would rather
masturbate than have sex with a person
sure that's where the addiction starts
to [ __ ] you up
but it's not like she came into a room
butt-naked you're like babe got a
[ __ ] jack off like you stare at her
just to collect the information and then
you walk into a that's an addiction
right you know what I mean sure yeah she
was just jumping jumping to the to the
religious she did grow up in a religious
family but I don't think that's what it
was I mean she had issues with her dad
too and like there was there was a whole
back
zero for Patrick it's my fault but that
was the longest relationship I've been
in and porn me jerking off is kind of
what [ __ ] it and most harmless thing
ever did 28 years and still running dude
yeah love it should have never said you
weren't gonna do it man
she just told her just been straight up
from the beginning yeah but I wanted to
[ __ ] so you want to get it in just
should have compromised weather so fine
I won't jack off every time I'm horny
you have to suck my dick you have to how
about that we've only known each other
for two weeks
that's how unreasonable you are yeah I
mean so I can be an unreasonable human
being as well yeah you're upfront with
it that's that's important yeah you got
to be real when I was like like super
super fat this is like one of those
turning points where I start to realize
I was really chunky I was laying in bed
and I was breathing really hard and I
was watching some [ __ ] on my iPad and
then Mary Lyall woke up she turned over
she goes are you watching porn right
next to me and then she turned grab my
iPad and I was watching I was looking at
a food recipe because Thanksgiving was
coming up and Thanksgiving yeah she's
like are you is this a food recipe I'm
like yep I don't have time to mash me
today is your dick out David they were
there breathing like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] crazy man I don't think
I've ever that's so unreasonable how do
you talk to somebody like that's I mean
I was trying to but it just wasn't it
wasn't clicking it just wasn't like it
was I yeah it's like trying to explain
to somebody that's really religious that
like you don't think God exists like
they was like hey like we just there was
no whatsoever acrossing her mine was
ready she was she was a she it was an
insecurity on her on her end so I still
keep in touch no not really
we talked a little bit afterwards you
just said her porn links and stuff yeah
horn huh
that's [ __ ] hilarious a deep Throne
[ __ ] part three that's probably the
only way about this I spy the only way
you can get her on board if you just
keep setting your links and then
eventually she'll be like oh you know
what porn isn't that bad I kind of like
it I think honestly the experience she
had with me is probably helping her now
I hope so anything she realized it's
pretty [ __ ] normal it's normal yes
she's like beta guy yeah like all guys
are gonna lighter there's no way yeah
dude there's no way yeah
no way that there isn't a guy that
doesn't watch porn and even if there is
there's no way that that guy doesn't
ever desire and or think another yeah
it's just impossible they may not say it
out loud but when they're jacking off
their death and not jacking off to you
yeah what they luck and we should be
real to like why why do we have to act
like that's not the case you know I
obviously you don't want your partner to
be like a damn look at that guy's fine
it's [ __ ] guys don't be a [ __ ] yeah
but like you know my business complex
too like that's just a clear sign of her
not understanding what number one what a
what a guy is like and it's very I think
it's kind of ignorant on her part to
assume that this is how a guy should be
when he how he should treat a woman it
is what a real man is yeah it's like
what is your foundations but what is
your foundation and your basis for that
statement because I'm a guy and I'm
telling you that a majority of guys
there there might be a few guys that
don't watch porn
sure few right but I really doubt that
there's a guy out there that doesn't
lust after some other girl not not in a
very serious way but like for me to like
I follow some scantily clad women I mean
I saw some flu season doggins I mean
sure it's normal yeah a couple of loose
women here and there man it's like if I
ever meet them in person I'm not gonna
like pursue them and they're not gonna
ever care about me either yeah it's just
in my mind I look at this woman and I
haven't met her because she hasn't
opened her mouth yet so she's attractive
to me that's the breaking present in my
mind that girl has the exact personality
that I like yeah
which doesn't exist except for in Muriel
you are perfect that's what did she's
the one dude you guys are getting
married
dude our man hey me and Mary we're I'm
engaged to her oh yeah that's right damn
and she's she's the lab we're gonna get
to officiate your wedding Jesus Christ
himself Wow last night I was like yo
cases crystal king yes I mean they saved
the day and when he came down look just
like Heinrich it was crazy
let's head it on your chest you trying
to [ __ ] get locked out of [ __ ]
[ __ ] mistake dog singles the way out
awful [ __ ] [ __ ] man and the homie
Joker dog he could officiate your
wedding dude I won't be there that day
for there's this [ __ ] Instagram that
cracks me the [ __ ] up
it's not wild yes it is who's gonna
watch the world's great number one news
I'm one of the funniest things I've ever
seen in my life to everything there was
a guy he was riding a bike and then on
the back he had like a little rig and
there was a chair like like a garden
like a garden chair just stuck in the
middle and I guess it was for like a
rickshaw it was like a it was like a
[ __ ] rickshaw and it was called foo
burr and he was riding around like
giving people rides on that's [ __ ]
tight that's dope you got it yeah you
know make it work that the weird thing
is is the the accent that I always [ __ ]
around a mess around is it pertains only
to East LA yeah that's it Spanish does
not sound like yeah so what people are
like yo why don't you imitate a
Salvadorian person I'm like because I
don't know what it sounds like
I just know what everybody sounds like
here yeah so you know and who called me
out oh it was Gio Gio was like you
always do it East LA accent I'm like
isn't that how you guys say well I can
only pull from the stuff that I hear
every day right you know and when we
were doing the the film goop there was
just one dude that actually irritated me
because I read this this review and they
said that the depiction of the Mexican
characters in guk wasn't real to how
real Mexican people are and the [ __ ]
funny thing was it was like dude the guy
that we casted great actor he's actually
a [ __ ] East LA he was just being
himself I guess he's like a former
gaming or some [ __ ] but he's a great
actor now [ __ ] amazing guy and I
remember at the after-party I show him
the review he goes oh I should talk [ __ ]
what the bow you mean you know be like
the guys like funny that's just who he
was exactly
himself and he [ __ ] killed that role
he had a couple as homies world through
two and that's just how they are really
good dudes yeah and and it was so it was
so weird that somebody who has never
lived in LA never been around like East
LA Mexican folks would sit there and say
oh that's not what real East LA Mexican
people are like it does that political
[ __ ] I show Fu's got wall to
everybody that I know that lives out
here right and they know what's up yeah
broke and they think it's hilarious just
because it's they all went to school or
they all growth with people like that
there are people that sound like that
yeah people that don't like it's it's
funny because you definitely like that
like all faucet bioship first of all
dude you're not even mixing your white
so how the [ __ ] and you live in like
George always white [ __ ] like
it's no you don't even live here so how
would you know yeah exactly yeah like
what the [ __ ] are you saying yeah they
just want to complain about some
[ __ ] I mean like social justice
warriors are annoying as [ __ ] to begin
with but the white ones are like extra
annoying dude they try so hard it's like
yeah stop trying so [ __ ] hard and
it's like a sneaky way to be controlling
it's like where's in compassion and [ __ ]
like yeah it's such a weird thing to cuz
I think it's the the weird conversation
that's happening now is a lot of people
like to use this word a lie that's all
you have to be a lie to our race but
what is this a [ __ ] race war yeah
what's going on [ __ ] up dude and it kind
of creates more division to have to be
an ally it's like no well now you're
making it sound like we're in this war
cuz I don't like that [ __ ] you know and
so there's always there's always a
couple of like white people that have to
constantly beat up on the fact that
they're white and that makes them more
accepting that people gas them up
they're like yeah you know what's up you
know that you're not supposed to like
benefit off these other people it's like
well you could just live and just be
respectful like a normal human being
could be cool with every night and be
chill with they're like well I don't get
why people have to go on social media
and talk about like like people [ __ ] on
white people so hard right and it's like
you're not gonna get you're not gonna
get anywhere just like saying like that
type of [ __ ] like yeah the answer to if
there is an answer to racism it's not
more racist you be a cool person if you
see some racist [ __ ] obviously you could
attack that but like other than that
just be cool and I love racism jokes
know for sure I'll do the best yeah I
mean I think a and they're all over
various right we said when you to take
your own race it you can make fun of
that [ __ ] sure or sometimes even when
you're not within my race and you know
all the inside jokes yeah it's hilarious
I I think we're allowed to poke fun of
it as long as is put as a joke that's
real too if it's real and it's like you
know it's like hard Jason always cracks
[ __ ] racist yeah dude he's talking
about the asian asian guys walking on
the neighborhood and there's always
slapping their leg it's the funny [ __ ]
is like an inside joke cuz that's real
that's so real dude you drive around out
hambar at 6:00 a.m. in the morning all
the dads are out all the grandpa's just
slapping their legs
we're like she yeah doing tight that the
[ __ ] guy got kicked off of SNL right
right ways that I think people were
upset because there was no joke so I
think I was like oh cuz I watched it a
few times is like I'm not really like
crazy upset at it yeah but then at the
same time when I did a video on and I
was like oh these not joking he just
doesn't like he just [ __ ] hates H
people like oh you might actually just
hate Asian people cuz I thought he was
like making up I thought there's like a
bit yeah but I don't think it was him
well it was more the it was the other
guy the other guy well he could he
couldn't wait to say it that his brother
or something I don't know but like a
part of me was because we were talking
about it and after the second time I
watch it I was like oh the first time I
was like this guy is annoying what yeah
he's he's annoying I want to punch his
face but the second time I watched it I
was like like I get it like maybe they
are trying to like trying to be funny
there the attempt is there but it was
just like so bad that it looks like he's
speaking from the heart
but it's also looking at his face so I
was like oh he turns up a joke and so I
was kind of waiting yeah a punch line
and I was like oh oh he just oh he just
don't like yeah yeah because it's it's
easy to like - damn it in their head
they're like punching down you know I
mean like they're just like I'm at
Matty's you know so it's a yeah see it's
hard to like if you're if you're trying
to be funny I think it's it's all ghosts
even if you don't land like you said
like yeah you're it's still like you
didn't it might not have landed like me
playing the guitar would sound like [ __ ]
yeah
same thing but it doesn't make you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if ya if you're just
meaning [ __ ] then obviously like you're
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah good I
think Joe Rogan was like now he was like
he was he was joking I'm like Joe Rogan
I don't think I agree with you on that
one yeah didn't because I know a lot of
people who just make Asian jokes that
aren't Asian and I laugh all the time
yeah there's no joke in that one so I'm
just waiting for the joke yes that's how
I made all my good friends in like high
school and like middle school I was just
thinking about this the other day I had
a buddy so we grew up with two ryan's
one was fat Ryan cuz he was fat and the
other one was black Ryan because he was
black
we called each other and me and black
Ryan were always racist to each other
all the time like in a funny way like
you would be [ __ ] telling me that
like he saw my my family hopping the
border and [ __ ] yeah the white blue-eyed
devil he was hitting me on the Mexican
and the way like I saw your family on
cops like and we would laugh and play
soccer and it was just it was just some
[ __ ] like it wasn't it like I think
also too when this [ __ ] yeah
dude when you grow up around like people
who just I got I use as example before
like I met this kid we're friends in
elementary school and I saw him again as
an adult not too long ago and when I
spoke to him he had a thick ass [ __ ]
Filipino accent my whole life I didn't
know that he had a Filipino accent
didn't register in my head but this one
just came on as I I haven't seen you in
so long David how have you been I'm like
the hug why do you keep doing this
Tagalog accident like cut that [ __ ] out
like it's me David's yeah and a play a
joke and then um met with another friend
because I was back in Sacramento so just
kind of seeing all the old homies and he
was like no he's had a axises elementary
school oh really
it completely went over my [ __ ] head
but I use that as a point just to say
like I think when we were younger I
don't really think about the race stuff
like we're just all friends and we just
hang out and we just poke fun at each
other all the time and that is really
it's not meant to hurt you it's just
meant to make you laugh yeah you're
you're trying to make your life a story
and I think just sometimes where people
confuse that in psych you get to say
that to your friends because you had
that rapport just be careful when you
say to a stranger and rightfox
sure yeah when you say that you do have
to take the responsibility of oh I'm not
just saying it to my friend right I'm
saying it to everybody else in the world
which is probably that's what happened
to this to Shane and his friend true
where they were yeah it's a podcast and
you're having a conversation but you're
also broadcasting it out to a gajillion
people yeah it's like it's like people
who think they have the the the passport
to the n-word everywhere right because
let's just be real there's a lot of
people still use it that aren't black
you got to earn that and there's a lot
of wherever you go and there's a lot of
black people that or a handful of black
people that think it's okay within that
small group but they also know that you
know when you go off to this other
neighborhood don't be using that word
yeah oh you like we do and I give you a
pass cuz you're my friend so it's
definitely not universal it's not and
even with like the black community like
you'll ask there's like black people who
hate other black people who use that
word weird weird thing like older black
men hate it when you know black men use
that word because that you word was not
cool in their generation right so when
they hear they [ __ ] cringe like I've
seen like older men like shake their
[ __ ] head yeah so just like a weird
that's just a word cuz that uh what's
that one celebrity that used it Gina
Rodriguez or some [ __ ] did you say [ __ ]
she was singing to a Fuji song on on
Instagram she post it and she drop the
n-bomb
oh really and then the whole [ __ ]
internet exploded to shed on her just
shat on her and she goes uh you know I
just wanted to pay respects you know
like I love Fugees I love the black
culture or whatever but at the same time
it's like [ __ ] why would you post a
[ __ ] yeah yeah you knew yeah what you're
gonna do sit why would you post a [ __ ]
let's say like you even had like all
your friends are black and they're cool
with you saying it that's not a
universal thing and you just avoid those
proper-- like you don't know problems
don't thought was that yeah that is not
and anybody who just like you don't ever
need to say the word it's not a big deal
especially in a song where you could
just you know just not post it it just
there's no need for it you know aim is
like well why can't I say why do you
need to say it that right question like
what do you need what's what's the big
deal yeah don't say it right like so how
does it do for you right now
Oh sometimes though I do be slipping up
I mean that [ __ ] could I go back to
Sacramento and you know all my homies
are black and [ __ ] and then we're
talking now son it slips I'm like I
think god I'm just around you guys I'd
be [ __ ]
one little Instagram story my career is
over we have audio of you
that's why I step in front of my ship I
already put it on the podcast every now
and then it slips up yeah yeah you just
got to be a front
yeah and just be honest about it and and
also like people are just too quick to
apologize and it's like if you didn't do
something wrong don't [ __ ] apologize
yeah I'm like [ __ ] it dude especially
when it comes to jokes like that [ __ ]
drives me [ __ ] crazy dude
yeah it's it's weird when I see I mean I
think I uh I made a joke once on Twitter
why I apologize for sure because I'd
made fun of a shooting at a massacre it
was a little funny okay most people
liked it but there was like a fat chunk
that were really pissed and I apologized
because I don't know people died I
thought they shot and then everybody
lived and so I just made a quick a quick
joke because I was supposed to go to the
Gilroy Garlic Festival uh-huh and that's
when the shooting happened
that it's kind of did a fake a fake like
headline I said breaking news because
you know it's the whole Tim famous joke
yeah I was like breaking news local
comedian dies from a shootout and Gilroy
Garlic Festival next to a random
stranger my cousin actually died there I
was like I'm good I actually felt bad
yeah I thought because I the I think the
article that I read when it first came
out there was no body count everybody
survived nobody got hit so that's why I
made the joke but then you know what I
forgot a handful of people passed away
and I was like mm I actually feel so bad
whatever your pieces felt a little bit I
was like I'll cancel David so hey man I
already apologized I stepped in front of
it I told the reason why that I'll take
away because I think it's just that it's
a little fresh yeah it was a little
fresh somebody if the family just dies
like well bro you already handled it
it's like it is what it is yeah like
that I'll apologize for for sure that's
like my bad 100% and I didn't really
know and people do have to understand
that the first article came out and
nobody died so I kind of went off that
but then after you know they did those
yeah body count that's understandable
whatever dude well the important part is
that you personally actually did feel
bad about it like I did wrong I Mac
erectus
well are you when it's like pressured
and it's something that you're like it's
you don't feel bad about it or something
but people are trying to like pressure
you and apologize and like [ __ ] you dude
like yeah just trying to be funny yeah
you know I could have used the argument
to that at mode
geordie people found it funny people
were cracking the [ __ ] up yeah I think
it got like a thousand likes and like
what do you call is it like sore thumbs
up or some [ __ ] on Twitter [ __ ] old
ass dude
but a guy quarts yeah hearts or some
shows like 1k plus in like a matter of
like two three hours so a lot of people
like my [ __ ] doesn't pop it was hot so
people did find it funny yeah but quite
a few who did it dude yeah if that's how
it goes though people trip on get a
shooter shot dude
you gotta shoot your hot shot Twitter
it's like one of those spaces to where I
it's just it I actually love Twitter now
Twitter is [ __ ] there's some people
who say some [ __ ] funny it's really
slow yeah yeah even something really
small like there was this girl who uh
she was like looking good today I gotta
show y'all with with a complete 360 and
right and then she just did a 180 and
she walked away and this dude literally
wrote he goes you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
of 180 just died laughing cuz she's so
[ __ ] fine they give a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
yeah Twitter's great dude I love Twitter
man it takes a probably a good 30
percent of my time really I don't go on
Twitter just because it's like another
thing to look at but maybe I will maybe
I waste just focus on your Instagram and
work on your business that posting on
Instagram is like want to see I have to
post on Instagram too and I never do I
[ __ ] never do yeah I'm an [ __ ]
start bawling dude once you just log in
just just start who the [ __ ] I want to
see your vlogs dude I want to see your
voice yeah all the mating rituals you do
with TIFF yeah yeah okay I'm gonna take
another crack at trying to have sex with
my fiance and now let's see how it goes
let's see how it goes Ivan I'll show it
and then after was like alright guys I
think I [ __ ] up here where I just went
right for the vagina and didn't kiss her
oh just call your vlogs another crack
another crack surpass him again I'm
gonna jerk off for like 10 minutes or so
I'll see you guys after but see you in a
minute hey guys it's your boy Nick the
[ __ ] ear and today I'm gonna try out
Davis technique and do a couple right on
the puss you set up the little GoPro on
the side so she doesn't really know like
hey babe kiss her on the neck and well I
probably do it too much I go too hard
like
then she's like yo like what the [ __ ]
what are you doing is it and I'm like
you dip out yeah I had to try it out
vlogging in your room when she's not
there and you start crying
yeah they go man just it's hard man I
just and then I'll probably like get so
many people just like oh man I totally
know what you're going through and like
people I'll probably blow up the
following yeah yes once I some you had
sex it's been a while since I could yeah
probably but last time yeah before
another pneumonia hey he must be beady
and hard right now you can even say
pneumonia he's so sexually frustrated
more than their money my lips are
quivering damn yeah I'm just getting hot
just thinking about good [ __ ] she's on
the road to recovery and guys I think
it's gonna happen soon yeah doc just
wait till you hit your [ __ ] solid 30s
man that sex drive starts to disappear
does it that actually sounds kind of
nice it does you know what I want I'm
not sure if it's like the sex drive that
disappeared so much cuz I still want to
have sex but I just uh I can control it
better you know I mean I want that in my
mid-20s that's I couldn't stop thinking
about sex all the [ __ ] time it was
annoying yeah it's like somebody would
walk in and they would show ankle ash
and I'm like what does the rest of that
ankle it was so [ __ ] annoying like I
just remember being at that age and just
constantly [ __ ] horny now I am
constantly horny but now I could have a
conversation with my penis but hey men
not today bro relax and then he goes but
he's always a little alert though he's
like sleeping but with one eye open like
he's ready to wake up yeah he's like
he's ready for it he's called up it's
like pretending to sleep just like a
[ __ ] five hundred me he's ready to go
though which is good you have an alert
day I feel like it's gotten like because
everyone talks about in high school
you're you're at your horniest but like
for me like I was horny and I go but
like it's like almost getting more
intense
does this ever chill the [ __ ] out like I
wanted to tell you hey I'm in I got a
relaxed I think I got [ __ ] to do I got
errands and things to run you felt like
I don't like being too horny them
No it's the worst working out helps a
lot though it does you know working out
actually sometimes like increases the
testosterone Oh does it not for me man
when I was when I was at my fattest I
was the horniest and I was the most
disgusting really what kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] is that God huh yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] up
yeah like when I was bigger I was horny
all the time annoying hmm I don't know
what I think because I wasn't expending
enough energy
maybe I'm just like storing all that
[ __ ] and whatever [ __ ] Mariel came
through she was like all right yes I
could tell Dave is breathing really loud
he wants to have sex he's looking at
cranberry recipes again warming up with
that cranberry pre-gaming its pregame
he's free game of cranberry recipes I'm
being strong enough being a [ __ ] fat
guy is kind of annoying I'm not thinking
ahead I could ever go back to that [ __ ]
no I don't think you I don't think you
will
it's too I cuz you saw a life on the
other side here like this is way better
you know there's like this whole
movement about you know big people are
beautiful too I get it did I was a big
guy my whole life like I completely
understand that but I I just have this
weird thing of like don't talk about
health and don't talk about those things
are two separate things right like yeah
you can be a bigger person and you can
still be relatively healthy in terms of
like being active but the conversation
of that is just that they're like okay
but what defines healthy there's like if
I if I did this this and that like I
work out I walk how come I'm not healthy
because you fat tub of lard just like me
I also played ball I also moved around I
did whatever but what I ate what I put
in my body was [ __ ] terrible and it
didn't offset that so when people say
they exercise and it's way they play
ball right yeah they they probably just
don't work that hard and in general like
they might think they dem shooting
around for 15 minutes like oh I play
basketball today that's not the same as
running five five you know games
full-court five-on-five you know that
that's not the same thing right and some
people will they work out and they lift
weights or whatever like they can't get
any gains or whatever and they're just
not working out hard enough and the food
is huge the food is like people and
people think they do everything right
but most of the time they probably don't
cuz I didn't really hate myself from
being a fat guy because I just never
really took that into consideration and
I did hate the way I felt
you know I mean like my joints were
[ __ ] hurting I couldn't be as active
as I as I want it to be yeah do my shits
were crazy dude
I just thought blood was supposed to be
in your poop all the time yeah you're
just have diarrhea all this yeah I was
like doom and liquidy poops all right
guys we should solid ill dr. monster
probiotic and weird oh yeah why do you
why do you even a toilet people yeah
nothing to wipe but butt from when you
were fat and then you lost all the
weight like you did a lot of you changed
a lot of lifestyle yeah and I just
generally was a lot happier being
thinner because I'm not thin but I'm a
shit-ton healthier yeah this is the
weight that I could stay at and I think
I'd be pretty okay like I know what it
takes to lose the extra weight to be
like in terms of like fitness to be a
lot more elite I guess I think I like my
hot dogs I like pizza I just don't have
to eat it 14 times a day yeah I don't
have to go to a venire 26 tacos every
[ __ ] you like eat seven tacos go to
sleep wake up and you know the burrito
you know who does that right so now I
just like I'm like I think the body is
very smart too once you kind of like
kick that addiction for carbs and have
heavy fats your body will say yo man I
don't feel good
yeah and I'll make you pay for that holy
every time I stood a I was gone for some
foods for a week worst day of my life
this dude came in pale I just looked
like he was like doing exercise you know
like I need something good no it was all
bad today you know but that's just what
happens when I when I mistreat my body
just by drinking a [ __ ] time yeah but
you're also aware of that and you
understand that relationship yeah yeah
but I would ignore that consistently
it's very easy to ignore it when it
becomes your norm yeah so me feeling bad
was normal so that was just everyday
life so you don't know what you're
missing until you kind of really fix
that part I see so like for example just
like walking like I remember Mariana we
get into arguments because she would
park too far like look at me [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] serious knees hurt it's like
it's easy to park out here but I'm like
there's a [ __ ] parking spot the fraud
like the fattest thing I could ever get
angry oh wow you know and I would get
mad about that [ __ ] because it was too
far and I knew
and be tired yeah that's some [ __ ]
dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard in
my life and now like it now if she parks
far I'm just like Co Co whatever yeah
these legs are ready to go I need a
[ __ ] weight training infants been a
minute I know but you've been also gone
for like two weeks - yeah it's been kind
of rough but you know you're back and
you're ready to go baby yeah man it was
pretty fun today - the [ __ ] he
stabbed me the idea that guys room with
the [ __ ] room I was walking out and
like David ran headfirst into the broom
oh no I was sis I was standing having a
conversation with Jason he spotted he
stabbed me in the eye with a broom I'm
like [ __ ] look back and I go oh did I
hit you did you run into that I'm sorry
man this is after I got psych kicked in
the testicles
yeah yeah and then he broke his shin
kicking someone's knee yeah it was one
of those days man you did great though
man
you did great I was proud of you went
out there and you gave 110% I gave it
12% and even when you hear what's funny
is like you kept getting signs to stop
like you know maybe just chill set up
these rest of the rounds but every time
you would train again you would [ __ ]
get hurt [ __ ] and then you're like you
know what I'm gonna get back in there
and usually your inclination is like I'm
gonna stop like I'm not gonna [ __ ] go
back I thought I'm done he went out
there and they got psych kicked in the
balls and I was like this is a sign this
is done listen after that he stopped but
then he went back out there and I was
like oh David look at you and you know
it was fun to have Jason back again cuz
that guy so usually when Jason's in
there Kim's out Jason Kinser yeah Jason
Kenzo Kinlaw man it's nice to get beat
up by him yeah because I think my
advantage that I have when I spar other
people they're like three inches shorter
than me it doesn't exist the only way
four inches whatever dude by five the
whole foot a man whatever you know the
guy's inches are a little weird it's not
existent we have like similar reach and
he's way stronger than me so it's like
oh I gotta figure something out
yeah Guinness mix it up yeah having
length in an in a fight is a huge
advantage oh it's everything it's a
massive size John Jones be knocking
everybody yeah but so ya know it's good
that you get that look - especially if
you can get someone that's even taller
so you can figure out how to fight it
because like I'm used to having a long
reach because I'm 511 but I have a long
and limbs but I like going with guys
like Jason cuz I'm the little guy now
and yeah I gotta get in on this but do I
mean it's very interesting cuz you go at
him dude and I'm just I'm too timid it
was so fun once you guys departed I just
have to [ __ ] it like you just filmed the
whole thing and try to bully him and get
in there and just throw your hooks and
work his body like you cuz if you stay
in it like he's just gonna pick you
apart yeah yeah he's gonna play his game
so like it's either all the way out so
he can't hit you or all the way in and
like pressing them and getting in there
boom ba-ba-boom hmm cuz you can't [ __ ]
around like he's too long he's way too
he'll sniper you you gotta at least make
him tired yeah chairman work the body a
lot tire him out with the body and then
and then go up to his head cuz his
head's too far away he can move away
easy yeah but a few fees focusing on his
body and then you throw a cup any stir
his head movement is deceptively fast
yeah it's weird it's really weird and
it's just just enough to get away and it
was so fun watching you guys spar cuz
you guys were throwing everything is
thrown push case you guys are kicking of
the body punching to the head punching
to the body like you guys were doing it
all and it was so fun to watch you guys
just go at it and it was consistent you
guys probably sparred for like seven
eight minutes seven eight minutes
straight and then just kept going I was
at a really high pace I was [ __ ]
exhaust but how you guys were like I'm
cool man like yeah it was it was so fun
to watch I cut my head he was tagging me
and I was like I see it coming but I'm
too tired to move my face bug it so when
you when you let's say cuz you know
Jason he likes to use his reach really
really [ __ ] well and I'm always I'm
so scared so you literally just you just
take one and you try to give like two or
three back sure yeah I try to I don't
want to take any yeah like I'm trying to
like use my head movement or like set up
my kicks to like to jump in with the
punches yeah but sometimes yeah you get
tagged but like just answer back with
something a leg kick boom and if you can
press him up against the wall or Corner
him do that because you're he's breaking
his rhythm and it's like it's a battle
of both of them trying to like stop you
from he's trying to forward yeah and
he's coming forward and then every time
Jason's throwing you're like kicking his
legs kicking his body punching him right
back like he's pushing your head and
you're punching his bite like you guys
are going back and forth long time but
it was so cool cuz and then you guys
were stopping back and forth and also
you tired dudes out like that too like
if you because the
whole thing you hear fighting at your
pace or fighting it yeah them if you can
actually impose your rhythm on somebody
else you [ __ ] up their breathing
patterns and they're always like kind of
like tripping so they're draining energy
without even knowing it because they're
tense they're not relaxed like you look
so you look at max Holloway Brian Ortega
like that
yeah prime example right put the foot on
the gas and was like you do it I'm just
gonna [ __ ] wear you out and just beat
the brakes off you right yeah it's the
same type of mindset you know right so
like that's what I was trying to do to
tire them out with just the pace like
just trying to get cuz he was like he
was always having to move or think about
something yeah like cuz you're gonna
spar Jason you're gonna get hit first
100% hundred-percent that if he's yeah
but you have to not necessarily get hit
and then like freak out you have to be
hitting and then already in response to
be hitting him back yeah that's the
thing I always get [ __ ] up on cuz I'll
throw listen yeah if I throw something
he hits me then I stop and my exhaust
[ __ ] and then you don't throw anymore
you throw something anything throw
anything go or just try to respond with
something and also just accept it you're
gonna get hit 100% you're getting
punched so [ __ ] let's just let's just
jump in there but then you throwing
while he's throwing and you defending as
much as you can and throwing back with a
proper rhythm and the proper like shot
selection makes him hit you less over a
period of time yeah he's also just I
think like different from the other
people that come in because he's more
seasoned you like what 10 years well
he's been trained for a while yeah
anything I mean he's he's one of the few
guys that actually is like watching you
yeah and seeing what you do yeah and
making adjustments off of that he does
very rarely do you get like not rarely
but like it takes someone with a pretty
high level or a pretty like expansive
knowledge base for them to kind of see
what you're doing and then adjusting off
of that in real time yeah cuz it's tough
he doesn't get the same one too now he
he adjusts all the time so I'm so used
to just everybody throwing all [ __ ]
one two or a low kick and a body kick
that I'm used to just pairing those but
he throws these hooks these [ __ ]
uppercut I'm like [ __ ] I'm not used to
addressing this ya know that's well
that's experienced so like at first you
start off with just like the combos that
you know hmm
you know you've drilled threes and a low
kick or two and a low kick yeah I want a
double jab right knee so you're kind of
still thinking too much but like once
you get into like his his experience
range and like I
been doing it for a while too I you just
kind of start like morphing to the
situation which is what you want like
you want to just adapt to whoever you're
here you're going against like me I was
coming in and ducking my head a lot so
he started throwing uppercuts uppercuts
so and I noticed that and I was like
okay feed it feed him like little faint
so you would do that and then I would
try to counter that so that's when you
just started playing chess and you're
like all right what he's doing I'm gonna
try to feed him this information and
like try to do this and it's a it's
crazy because fighting is so cerebral
like people think that yeah roots like
[ __ ] rap but it's like it really is
like there's a lot of thinking there's a
lot of like will like imposing your will
on somebody rhythm like that repetition
too and just being able to see that look
so much where it just becomes instinct
yeah because I don't because nobody ever
throws hooks except you know you know
you guys you know so when he threw a
hook I try to parry it like it was a jab
and then he [ __ ] me up and I should
have just [ __ ] covered up pulled it
off and throw another one but right I
kept on pairing you like a jab so like
when you sparked when we do the
isolation drills right we did like body
like low-key lead leg kicks only right
you sparring with with say Chris yeah
has the same amount of weapons it's a
very different experience than we spar
with Jason yes right because he's able
to maximize his weapons and his shot
selection with the same amount of
attacks he attacks and defense exact
yeah and he and he's able to change the
variables with very small amount of
variables and yeah it's an equal playing
field but he's able to see what you're
doing change it and play his game and
make you react a certain way and then
keep changing and every single time he
does that it makes it a really hard
sparring around just because you know
he's able to maximize that ruleset yeah
so it's every time you spar with a guy
like that he's it's just like he has a
very expansive vocabulary yeah yeah
right for a lot of things exactly that's
a great way to vocabulary language is
like very very and there's some guys
where they spar with and then you know
there's guys that Jason will spar with
and they'll make Jason look like [ __ ]
he's never spar today I mean it's like
yeah there's always the levels to it and
it's just really crazy to see but it's
good that you spar with them they you
should because the best bro with you'll
get better like without even if you
think you got beat up or whatever you
like
[ __ ] suck yeah still good it's like
bombing and stand-up like yeah bombed
like you feel like a [ __ ] idiot
you're like why am I doing this I'm a
loser
yeah but actually like you're learning
[ __ ] with not even know about it I
didn't get better yeah but I always go
after Jason Chen
hey Jason come on this party but you're
nice to Jason there of course like I'm
not gonna beat him up I just like it cuz
I get to slow down yeah let's work on
our jobs today and this flow always like
nope no Jason [ __ ] always we got
worried about you I can't [ __ ] take
my eye off you we talked about man
I put patty-cakes dude hey maybe that
hurts like that bakers I've been going
really light on the light spine though
yeah I just I think with Jason I just I
can't do the same thing not you can no
Jason you can go a little harder yeah
yeah if he wants he can take it he likes
it you might get mad at you he's like
dude [ __ ] just hit me he does so like
I would throw he goes amen hit me a
little harder I'm like because I you
know cuz with Chris or Bill he's so
skinny when I like light tip him it
hurts I could tell it hurts him a little
bit yeah I'm like he's also like 155
exactly so like even when we were
throwing the leg kicks
I would lay kicking my son like just
crumble it broke his [ __ ] he's up but
did I kick Jason and nothing moves right
so I'm also when you spar say you're
Jason Chen right and I saw this happen
with Jason Chen and big Jason Jason Chen
goes up to Jason big Jason he starts
kicking him and then tall Jason looks at
him and goes hey man hit me harder but
then I know Jason Chen's mine he's like
dude if I hit you harder like dude hit
me really hard
yeah and Jason wouldn't do that but it's
yeah he won't fear your head yes yeah
like those kind of guys you can hit them
Henryk you can hit heart too like this
Heinrich is used to it there's a
professional fight yeah he's a pro
fighter
Jason the guys the guys would think even
Alex like big Alex like you I'm a bull
look but yeah I was a sonic he's like it
was like nothing yeah that's like [ __ ]
dude he's [ __ ] my chance when he
checks a kick and he doesn't move
nothing's happening bro he's at all kin
tanked yeah he's massive he's mark hyung
is the juggernaut dude first you're
gonna he's the juggernaut I told you I
try to clinch him no completely dude all
that much
[ __ ] out the window describe me 700 like
that easy
he's tart is he lives cars then 130
pounds at his height - or is he like 5 6
5 6 230 230 dude he weighs 15 pounds
Toyota's Yoda Corollas he's lifting up
Nissan squats that suit looks cars crazy
dude so I mean if he competed he would
probably have to drop quite a few pounds
cuz he's fighting a 230 he's fighting
some [ __ ] hefty huge yeah
tall big dude [ __ ] that guy hits so
[ __ ] hard oh yeah for sure
when he lands a little bit and he's
still very early like yeah like him
training you know if if he were to train
like five days a week like six days a
week and like he kills me they dedicate
I'll bro he is he has the touch of death
for sure he's puttin [ __ ]
asleep yeah 100% he's massive he's a
[ __ ] monster and he's like he's
pretty athletic - oh yeah he's very
athletic he can move really well yeah he
does he's just too [ __ ] sometimes
he's so why'd he just can't [ __ ] like
move that well now he does move good
dude
you know who moves good is Brian Perry -
Brian Perry that dude moves good except
I mean my face so many times dude like
triple jab that's a half a second he's
very up he's quick he's actively fast
what is that [ __ ] did he look like Carl
Wilson he's just [ __ ] people up
kung-fu Panda he's like like a blob but
like that motherfucker's fast he does a
[ __ ] around dude if he just if he you
know really lost more weight and then
worked on his flexibility and he had
more kicks to his game let me dope yeah
he's mainly hands right now
yeah cuz when we spar I can always guess
which kick on him huh you know cuz his
midsection is a little bigger yeah but
then obviously when he gets into this
hand I'm [ __ ] yeah timings so good
he'll just punch you out of nowhere and
be like what the [ __ ] it's always
looking at angles he's always moving
angling angling angling I'm late - how
are your kneecaps not destroyed where's
this yes sorry this is clip of him
triple jabbing my face I didn't realize
how fast it was I just thought that way
okay okay alright yeah okay didn't even
see it happening
[ __ ] crazy yeah he's good as [ __ ] man
all those guys are really good they're
all fun to spar with you should spar did
I I shouldn't get that anger at ease
I should have been angry bro he's got
hate in his heart yeah and your heart
let it out yeah man let it out yeah yeah
I need you what it is it's like I was so
used to [ __ ] sparring and stuff every
now and then actually I wasn't even
sparring that much but every now and
then I like get it on my system or like
doing jujitsu even but I haven't been
doing that recently because and I just I
can feel it like oh dude it's inside of
me I gotta [ __ ] get the demon and
yeah I gotta like train or so there's
our energy yeah do some like really
[ __ ] hard cardio or something but
Monday dude get those rounds in not with
me but with somebody else somebody else
somebody who's a little more better than
I am whatever dude you [ __ ] punch me
in the head that's cuz I'm tall yeah
you're a [ __ ] too like you're
not like you act like oh babe like I'm
tall I'm so not good like please don't
hurt me that's you that's not and then
[ __ ] you take like is getting better
though otherwise you're really your
kicks I really good journey he's turning
this is inherently like a perfectionist
anything that he tries to put his
mindset to he's gonna try hard to like
make it look good
he's gonna he's gonna do that to the
best of his abilities until a certain
point where he's just like yeah but it's
still that intent is still good enough
for him to be like pretty decent but
then he will he'll be like sandbag like
oh man like I can't but because they're
games where it's it's weird with with
with martial arts because there's days
where it feels really good and there's
an age where it just feels like [ __ ]
nothing's piecing together right and
then I just walk away
how'd I go home and I'm pissed [ __ ] I'm
angry and then I just start watching
these videos I'm like this is what I'm
doing wrong yeah and I'll try to
refix it refix it refix it and that's
what it takes guys that's what it takes
to get [ __ ] good like you can't
[ __ ]
you can't just only train in the gym you
got a [ __ ] train outside you got to
do all the extra work I think like the
part that becomes fun is when I think
now I just it's a hobby now so I'm not
gonna compete I'm not gonna do anything
so now I just literally look at videos
I'm like I want to try this next week
that if once I once I do it and then all
of a sudden performance
down yeah cuz I met my goal I'm like oh
I did it I'm good
like don't you find something else that
like you know that she really keeps my
interest like that was one week where I
was literally trying to do this is guy
that I follow on Instagram he's like
this Russian dude but he literally did
this thing where you it's literally just
a suppose it was a call that [ __ ] it's
like a Superman punch you step and then
you step off side switch stances and you
switch it to a cross now strike this
[ __ ] all [ __ ] leaked and he lands it
and I'm like I'm good that's it one day
he came in and I saw him move in and I
was like have you been watching like
Steve and Wonder Boy Thompson I was like
bro cuz you're [ __ ] me up with it
stop watching those it's funny cuz I
like the way Wonder Boy fights like if I
wanted to fight fight I would fight like
Stephen wonder boy because I like being
able to pick and choose my shots get in
and out a lot
grab him is what I found out when I was
doing that I don't have the stamina
defined like that uh yeah cuz it lasted
maybe like 30 seconds it's too hard it's
too you have to have really good
conditioning I mean I tried doing like
you know I liked Dominick Cruz like I
loved his footwork that one week that
was exhausting exhausting David got
plantar fasciitis do Dominic hurt that
took him out like he had plantar fascial
yes cuz he was putting so much load like
a veal boom bouncing around and run it
around its footwork is so dope this is
so good I understand them because when I
was sparring with it why it's so dope
because it's so unpredictable yeah it's
it's hard to deal with yeah when you get
a guy that's bouncing in front of you
and especially if he's taller than you
or longer than you mean it's like a
[ __ ] truck yeah then then it's really
scary to deal with there's not a nowhere
to get punched in the face and you're
like oh you're over here now you know so
but yeah I just don't do that anymore
David I like so much to be the face of
time I'd never punch you you never spar
anymore yeah I need to you know man what
dude it's good it's really good I got a
watch sometimes cuz everyone
it makes me feeling easy because when
I'm training I'm only thinking about
that I'm not I don't give a [ __ ] about
anyone else next to me like as far as
like if whoever sparring behind me I'm
not focusing on that like I'm
with because you have to be otherwise
you get [ __ ] if I if I mindset is
somewhere else while I'm spawning or
Patrick Patrick's gonna [ __ ] kick me
in the face and knock me out so it's
like sometimes well I'm teaching class
like I have to make sure everyone is
being safe and controlled because
sometimes people will get out of hand
yeah so I have to make sure that they're
not like Beauty beating up guys like
Jason Chen who's only been training for
I have never beat up that little boy
ever data I've never beat up that you
know it's really hard to control the
punches if you're going in out those
because there's a lot of like inertia
that moves forward so I think that's
where those hard hits where David runs
through many loads of these paces in
crack times because because that karate
style is somebody's gonna like kick your
leg or move out the way if I'm going for
that that long jab to this gut and I'm
moving forward with my [ __ ] heavy
weight yeah it feels a lot harder than
I'm trying to hit yeah so it's always
but and then he always tells me to he
was fully extendable if I fully extend
it's gonna hurt that's why just bullying
stands as fast as he can and he just
snaps people's [ __ ] heads back but
that's fine though if that's what you
want to do okay
I'll learn how to do this life's boring
thing eventually just like a control
thing I murder the first time I sparked
like one of the first time as part of
Patrick he was the only person that was
nice to me they didn't beat the SH out
of me yeah he didn't know how to lunch
at all yeah I met him no I mean I was I
was just teaching him how to punch but I
guess the other guys were [ __ ] your
ass up is that my boy candy candy that
dude he's the biggest time when he's men
I've ever seen his brothers are also the
biggest Taiwanese deal like I wish I
can't find the footage but I have this
footage of this of Kenny just beating
the [ __ ] out of somebody just it was
Cody he was beating the living [ __ ] and
Cody's so funny so he goes I want to run
that back I'm like why Cody why piss
blood like are you [ __ ] and Cody was
like hanging in there but it's just like
Kenny's he hits harder and he's he's big
as [ __ ] and he sees it coming and
Kenny's got hate in his heart
Cody stomach like he lost his keys at
the bottom of a bag
I remember my first like the first time
I sparked a fight Academy and I was like
maybe like a couple months in and it was
sparring day and I was all like the
badass dudes that would just [ __ ]
everyone up there's big Russian cat beat
the [ __ ] I'm bloody my nose and I was
like okay that's cool I spar with my
dude Chris Fajardo and he had a lot
really long hair at the time and he he
would wear these crazy [ __ ] like
spats it was like it looked like jeans
they weren't and he would just beat the
[ __ ] out of me dude he was really hard -
he would uppercut me into [ __ ] like
oh dude my head would've hurt so bad
afterwards and then I would spar with
candy in the ring
I remember we touch gloves he would
always wear this [ __ ] red hoodie and
these high boots of shin guards these
white slip on high position guards so we
if anyone knows that that trains the
slip on shin guards are like quite thin
and Kenny is a big dude and he hits like
a [ __ ] truck
he's probably one of the heaviest hands
of I've sparred with like vaults like
it's hard as he is fine
he's a dense [ __ ] he low kick
just threw a jab at me and I covered up
and I didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on low kicked me so [ __ ] hard
and it probably wasn't even that hard
but it was at the time it was the
hardest I might as well be I hate my
truck I couldn't tell the difference
uh-huh he hits my leg I collapse hard as
[ __ ] and I'm like dude this is it I
can't spar anymore
I did three rounds that day I got beat
up by [ __ ] everybody decimated and
from that and then Kenny gave me one of
my [ __ ] he gave me one of my
concussions he gave me my [ __ ] ear
just from hookers yeah like I drained it
and it looked like this year it look
kind of like so and then he punched my
ear through headgear and it blew up so
bad and I would feel like blood swell I
immediately felt blood fill up in my ear
well I would move my head and it would
slosh around
I had like a capri-sun here dude like it
was all my gosh no matter how many
needles I used it just never like it
never drained fully and we keep filling
up and it just hurts so bad I feel like
just watching the videos that you show
me on YouTube I think Kenny could have
gone pretty decently far
because he has the drive good and he has
like the he's self-motivated anyway
hi the whole time yeah I remember like
you're one of the playgrounds like like
bait or else to do that they used to do
proving grounds like MMA fights that
fight Academy yeah and I remember I was
in the back and he was like warming up
and I'm like what's up Kenny how you
doing man how you feeling
it looks him he's like dog I'm high as
[ __ ] like what all right and then he
knocked the guy out
like dude ah what's up [ __ ] this dude
faded the [ __ ] knocked him out with the
upper like beat the breaks off this dude
and then afterwards he walks around the
cage like this just that's that was a
celebration after no nice yeah just like
this cheeky Asian eyes pulled his eyes
back walking around the whole [ __ ]
cage and we just [ __ ] bow down to
that dude ever since of this from you
bring Kinion I always go as light as
humanly possible because I feel like if
I just by accident tag him it's on yeah
cuz I'm big enough so he's like with him
yeah yeah sure yeah if you hit him he's
gonna [ __ ] if Kenny just be really hard
I'm gonna scream Kenny Kenny's been
thinking but he's like dude I want to
get back in a kickboxing and he's like
oh I want to see him fight yeah yeah I
think he wants to cuz he he was doing
jiu-jitsu for a while and he just
[ __ ] destroyed everybody like his
last form that he did he went against
like four five guys and just [ __ ]
around the whole time and just beat
everybody when he would like switch
stance he would like what makes him so
damn good you know what it is it's
honestly his mindset like this dude when
he puts his mind to something he goes
after it and he nothing is gonna change
his mind and like he works hard like he
pushes himself to the limit like he's
just that guy damn when he wants to do
it if he doesn't want to do it he can't
be [ __ ] but he just wants to [ __ ]
around he like he wants to kick it with
a boy like he's like that dude like he
wants to be funny is the funnest dude of
all time he's always is but when he
decides that he's like you know what I
wanna I want to smash everyone at this
tournament he will train so hard and
push his bike he'll run three four or
five miles a day trained jiu-jitsu at
night have a full day job come back and
then do three classes and then wake up
in the morning and then like teach a
kickboxing class
and then do it all over and they go back
to work and do it all over again every
single day and then then he goes out and
then just smokes everybody at this
tournament cuz he knows he put himself
through the ringer and it but that's the
mindset you have to have if you want to
fight and you want to compete and you
want to do all that [ __ ] you got to be
that [ __ ] guy otherwise you're never
gonna be the best you know I mean in
turn like he does it over and over and
over and over again it's just because
he's self-motivated he does what he
wants like he gets after it and he
doesn't just he's looking for the
hardest guy in the room to train against
every single time he's he he wants that
energy but then you do that after a
while
it's [ __ ] draining it's it's tough
like it's you get to a certain point
where it's like I don't want to do this
anymore
III be martial arts just like how I play
basketball when we play ball I go
there's like a five on five I look at
the weakest person I come up to him I go
a place off I play soft I go for the
weakest person then we try to match each
other's energy yeah then then again
Kenny sometimes is just like he's in a
mood where he's like man I'm kind of
over it like let's do this and he just
like I remember after his first loss in
amateur he was like eight and one right
he lost us dude that just took him down
and held him down after that loss all he
did was just shadow box and and work on
his head movement for like probably
three four months straight didn't throw
any like I guarantee bro he didn't throw
any punches only punchy through was a
jab and then then he only developed his
cross that was it and then that became
his best weapons and he smoked everybody
after that he would outbox everybody you
know like it he would just do really
really well see that's that obsession
that I think that a lot of people don't
realize that you need when you want to
become excellent at something yeah cuz
sometimes people look at somebody they
just go oh that person he's just way
more talented than I am yeah it's like
but I bet you're not doing as much work
as a person as I do yeah like his
obsession you hear the stories about
like Kobe Bryant right yes dudes in the
gym after he they win a game or lose a
game he's in the court he's on P back in
the gym that night shooting until 4:00
a.m. yeah it's like yeah it's your life
it's like this is my side this is this
is what I'm whether I can be or not like
this is what he'd be doing right yeah
like
and that becomes the best part of his
game like that's what he gets known for
yeah that's why I always say like that
that repetition part is it's very
interesting because you know I don't I
don't get the train as much as I used to
especially when we first started and I
was I quit everything so I wasn't
working and that's why you got good
pretty fast he would he would we I would
train with him and I would look at
videos I'm like damn it doesn't look
like the other videos but I said on the
Internet so I would pray with him and
that would go home I would leave my [ __ ]
in the house I would do like this
three-mile walk and then I would go to a
tennis court cuz it had lines and we
were working with lines and stuff just
to you know keep my you know whatever
like but my feet my footwork is [ __ ] and
then I bought a ladder too so whatever
he did he taught me and I did that
[ __ ] every day every time we train I
didn't went back home and on the off
days I would practice that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time yeah and it became like a
obsessive all the [ __ ] time yeah but
then now it's like now that I noticed
that when I travel I'm gone for a week
or two I come back and it's just there's
no repetition and so there's no
connection to it yeah the kids are
unconnected like I'm it goes back to the
tech mundo kick again and like oh and it
takes like a few kicks just to get it
back to normal and great and it's just
it's hard like you know you really have
to just beat it in you until it becomes
just second nature well it's like you
got to do the grunt work dude like most
people don't want to do the grunt work
like they just you know it's they want
to do it when they feel like it but you
got to do it all the [ __ ] time well
even for me like I've been doing it for
like ten years now and like if I take a
few weeks off I can get back in the gym
I feel rusty too for a minute I'm like
oh my timing is off my jabs a little
sloppy my kicks aren't like the form
isn't there but like again you once you
get that groove down like you just get
back into it for a little while a day or
two and then you're back you know what I
mean but I can't tell you look like
you've been [ __ ] fighting every day
yeah I still look good yeah good I feel
rusty though like even today with Jason
like he was hitting me with things where
I was like I shouldn't be getting hit by
this but Laura party you party was like
like [ __ ] it just go for bro yeah I kind
of got into another like [ __ ] I don't
understand have fun when you're when
you're when you're charging towards him
and you're really pressuring him at that
point because you're within his range
you really have to what depend on your
head movement yeah a lot of head
movement and just being like in the
right position at the right time oh
because I'm never there I'm always in
the right position is Sara like Pat just
like doing the Mike Tyson bob and weave
those I'm like he's strategically
putting
head in a certain place while he's
throwing a certain punch or like he's
seeing kind of what he's going for or
like the the certain right scenario and
he's putting his head there and then
just very strategically he's never just
moving just the sake of the move right
I'm trying to like
soyou're because if so many things are
happening and once you're anticipating
what he's gonna do thinking about what
you're doing trying to play mind games
with him at the same time but without
actually thinking about any of it at the
same time if that makes any sense yeah
so like yeah I'm trying to like hit like
if I look back on it now like when I was
in his chest I should have like created
angles more cuz I would have helped me
get hit less like if I would like boom
boo-boom slipped off over here boom boom
slip back over here like if I would have
anticipated like don't punches and then
a defensive movement afterwards to get
out of the way or whatever that would
have been better but my legs weren't
there I was so tired I'm like [ __ ] you
like I'm just gonna try to hit them but
yeah so you're always just you're like
hitting but you're ready to defend or
move at the same time you have to beat
you to be like I'm throwing offense but
I'm also I'm at a seconds notice ready
to [ __ ] weave out slip out step back
step in even stepping in a range
sometimes it's good like clinch up get
them in a Muay Thai clinch yeah to avoid
any kind of punishment or whatever um
but it's just a matte it really is like
the the I mean it sounds corny like the
B Watership but like that's really what
you have to be like you know just be
adaptable to whatever situation happens
unless you have all your fundamentals in
place right you need them less unless
you're able to throw efficiently yeah if
you're able to throw technically and
you're not like wasting movement like if
Pat had a really shitty kick he wouldn't
be able to land half the [ __ ] that he
could have landed right his position
we're in that like cuz when you're in
that type of fight where you guys are
like flowing like you guys are pretty
much going back and forth the whole time
if he has a hitch in the way he throws a
punch if he pulls his hand back a half a
second late yeah or he throws a kick
half a second late it [ __ ] everything
up and his chances of getting hit go up
even more and his chances of hitting
somebody with that technique goes down
significantly yeah you know so he has to
be has he has to have that base and that
fundamentals to be able to
and not get hit the same everything is
based on the fundamental fundamental you
got it if you've had that's step one
that's like we stand up be funny first
like yeah be funny can you be funny for
10 minutes then if you're not doing that
then nothing else you know but yeah so
just the fundamentals and then the
experience and then also being relaxed
you have to relax
oh that's that is so hard but that but
that's but that's one of the major keys
like you just chill the [ __ ] out cuz
when you're chill you you'll just do
you'll move in certain ways and be like
right that just happened like ideas like
when I watch you guys spar to like the
one thing I do notice how relaxed you
guys are and when you take a hit you
understand that oh I mean you'll roll it
off a little bit and then you like every
time I get hit I'm shocked that I got
hit I'm like what the [ __ ] you're not
that mindset to be like I have to throw
something right away right back yeah it
takes you a little bit like sometimes
it's like it's still fresh yeah well
you're like oh [ __ ] like and then once
you get hit a couple times and you're
like oh okay now I have to be like catch
or block or get hit and then return with
something right back
also because I'm scared of throwing too
hard because if I get hit my immediate
reaction to throwing straight down the
middle you know but then I'm like it's
like because if I if I spar Bart I feel
like cuz he's bigger and he gave me the
okay to throw at him a little harder so
if he hits me I'm okay exchanging and
throwing one right back at down the
middle to him yeah but then you know
let's say if it was like you know Chris
you know like he's I'm just I'm like 60
pounds heavier than him so even if he's
faster than me I don't think his jab and
his punches are better but if I just hit
him once hard with a 215 20 pound dude
hit some straight down the middle is
gonna feel different yeah yeah but I
mean it okay it just it all comes with
the experience like you have no
experience you get the the more
controlled you be like in light like to
be able to throw back but be chill yeah
but that part but for now like with guys
like Jason or Bart like just throw just
throw that [ __ ] cuz like you need to do
that yeah sure and Jason's down dude
Jase Jase is a crazy [ __ ] he's
down to [ __ ] he's down to throw he's
down oh oh okay well if [ __ ] was hour
and a half
oh [ __ ] we're slowing to an hour no yeah
whatever it's all good
anyways guys there's a lot of a lot
[ __ ] what they call jacking off
talking a little porn pneumonia fighting
poor mostly porn addiction mental
cheating mental cheating mental cheat I
kept doing it right [ __ ]
krumping just our comas gonna blow up
they're gonna be like they're gonna be
slamming your DMS yeah like you're a
piece of [ __ ] watching [ __ ] porn you
stupid son of a [ __ ] well guys you
could catch us on Spotify stitcher
iTunes if you're on iTunes give us that
five star rating very important this is
a podcast about anything and everything
and we're just here to be with you on
your [ __ ] mundane everyday lives you
know sometimes I listen to my own
podcast and I laugh at my own [ __ ] yeah
narcissistic [ __ ] we made your commute
better yeah it's way better Patrick
where can they find you I just on my
Instagram it's just my name Patrick T
dot Reilly he and Nick were they can
they find you precise a dumpster Oh Nick
the ear at gmail and you know gchat you
guys on gchat hit me up on gchat thank
God Instagram